un passeport sanitaires voilà ce que les
pays du vieux continent veulent mettre
en place dès le mois de juin prochain
ce mercredi le parlement européen a
donné son accord à la généralisation
d'un certificat vert afin de rétablir la
libre circulation dans l'espace schengen
après les couacs en série sur la
vaccination et d'autres restrictions qui
diffèrent d'un pays à l'autre
à l'échelle de lieux bruxelles espère
une forme d'harmonisation pour la saison
touristique et fuck and deliver
politique les deux techniques oeil sur
lui si nous pouvons tenir nos promesses
sur le plan politique et la solution
technique sera prête à temps
si nous ne le faisons pas nous risquons
une fragmentation à travers l'europe
avec une multitude de solutions
nationales éventuellement incompatibles
nous risquerions d'avoir différentes
variétés de documents qui ne peuvent
être lus et vérifier dans d'autres états
membres et nous risquerions la
propagation de documents falsifiés et
avec elle la propagation à la fois du
virus et de la méfiance des citoyens de
spread of bone and much of 7 dans un
premier temps réticente à l'idée d'un
tel procédé
la france est depuis le 19 avril le
premier état de lieu à mettre en place
un pass sanitaires le document est pour
le moment expérimentés sur certains vols
à destination de la corse et serait
étendue à l'outre-mer à partir de la
semaine prochaine
plusieurs membres des 27 se montre plus
que réticent à l'égard de ce certificat
vert c'est le cas notamment de la
belgique et de l'allemagne
instaurer un passeport vaccinale à
l'échelle de l'europe avant l'été un
défi qui s'annonce périlleux pour
bruxelles